Speaker 1: All right. Let's let's keep
talking to people. Why not? Right. I mean,
we're here. We're all here. Let's
go to where are we going? Here? Oh,
I don't know. Why don't we go to our friend
attack from Denmark? It's been a while since
we've spoken. Welcome back.
Speaker 3: Hello. Hello?
Speaker 1: Color me. I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Awesome. Yeah. Note One of the reasons
why I've actually been gone for so long is because
I was actually in the military for the past couple
of months. Oh, wow. Basic training. So that's.
Speaker 1: That's the Danish military.
Speaker 3: Yeah. What is that?
Speaker 1: What is basic training like in Denmark?
Speaker 3: It's so it's it's four months total. So
basically if you go through all the basic threads
like you start out with theory and so forth,
you go through things like how do you move as
a unit? There's also a lot of physical training,
stuff like that. And then the final part of it,
you basically take part in all kinds of
exercise things where you have to simulate
attacks in enemy positions and so forth. So it's
a it's a whole thing, basically. But and this.
Speaker 1: Is something you chose to do.
Speaker 3: Yes, there is conscription in
Denmark. I was not conscripted. However, I
volunteered. I am planning on becoming an
officer in the Army soon enough, especially
as I recently finished my studies in the
university. So this is my next thing, basically.
Speaker 1: Interesting. And is that in Denmark,
is that a good career?
Speaker 3: As an officer
in the military absolutely.
Speaker 1: Interested.
Speaker 3: In why do greatest things
about becoming an officer actually is the
the training you get to do leadership training is
one of the most attractive ones in Denmark and you
can use it outside of the military as well. And so
my specific goal is to become a language officer,
where I will focus on being an interpreter,
basically with a special focus on Russian and
Ukrainian as languages I'm going to be using.
Speaker 1: Oh,
wow. What languages do you speak?
Speaker 3: I speak Danish, German,
English and very basic Russian currently.
Speaker 1: Okay. So your Russian would
have to improve to be able to do that.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And that's a thing that you
actually do in the language officer's training
program is you go through a language course.
That's one of the things. It's a 2 to 3 year
course that you go through. And after that you
basically are fully qualified officer and then you
get sent out on deployment for a year and a half,
after which you can work on a contract basically.
Speaker 1: And is, is this is my last
question and then we can get to your
question. Is the military in Denmark
similar to the U.S. in that there is lots of sort
of like toxic masculine alpha type stuff that goes
on or is it different in that sense?
Speaker 3: So this is actually super
interesting. The Danish military
is very much so. Not like that,
at least not any more. One thing I can tell you is
that when you see a lot of videos that you know,
you see drill instructors, what they, you know,
yelling at a soldiers and stuff like that. Yeah.
Doesn't happen to Danish military, at
least not my experience. If you screw up,
they will come over to you and say, oh, well,
if you did that wrong, go and do it again,
please. Right. Like that. Instead of saying,
You idiot, what are you doing? Blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, you know, you see, like what
else? I mean, those American like documentaries on
the U.S. military. Yeah, that's quite different.
Speaker 1: That's quite different.
Speaker 3: You'll find toxic masculinity
in there. Absolutely. But there are a
lot of women as well in the Danish
armed forces. Actually, in my course,
I think about a quarter of a stairwell, actually.
Women. Okay. You know, super interesting. That is.
Speaker 1: Interesting. But
it's interesting. Well, listen,
I've taken up so much of your time. I'm guessing
you had a question. Maybe. I don't know.
Speaker 3: Yes, I actually did have a question.
And that was actually I wanted to ask you about
I know that like the Ukraine war hasn't been a
very big thing recently on the show and not been
talked about a lot recently. But as of currently,
the Ukrainian war, you know, it's almost in a
kind of standstill and so forth. Yes, the front
lines aren't really moving a lot. There is an
offensive working to watch Chaos. I'm currently
from the Ukrainian side. And so my question is,
do you think as to public perception of the war
winds down in the west as we don't focus on it
as much anymore over domestic issues like
energy prices and so forth? Do you think
that Western support will continue? Being as
strong as it has been has been up until now?
Speaker 1: I think government support
will, but I think average, you know,
Ukrainian flags in the streets is diminishing.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I would definitely agree with
that. I think that a big, big problem that I see
is that people think because public perception
goes down, that government support will go down
as well. But I think that we've seen during
the war in Afghanistan, for instance, that we
haven't constantly heard about Afghanistan 24
seven for 20 years, right when we were still over
there. You know, Denmark was also in Afghanistan,
for instance. Yes. But just because it's not in
the news doesn't mean that support will die down,
because there's obviously geopolitical interests
at play here, because I don't think the US or the
EU want to get rid of it just because people don't
really want to hear about it that much anymore.
Speaker 1: 100%. I agree with
you. Yeah, I don't I don't think
that the government support will diminish.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And so my next question is,
do you think that it makes sense
for the United States, for instance,
to start training the Ukrainian military on
more advanced weapon systems such as Western
fighter jets and so forth, which is. Well.
Speaker 1: I think the answer is yes with
the asterisk of do they have those systems? And if
not, who's going to give them to them? That's the.
Obviously, there would be little sense in doing
the training if they're not going to have access
to those systems and or who gives them to them.
Speaker 3: Yeah. And that was something that I
saw was being discussed in Congress recently was
that he wanted to start supplying F-15s to Ukraine
after they started training Ukrainian pilots
in them. Hmm. So which is interesting because,
you know, when we look at the Ukrainian military,
we see a military that has been in many ways,
you know, influenced by the Soviet Union up until
2015, around when the Donbass war started. Yes,
indeed. And in many ways, NATO's the U.S. and
other Western countries are trying really hard
currently to reintegrate the Ukrainian military
from using a large part Soviet equipment to using
more Western equipment. Yes. And seeing, like the
way that it's been escalating slowly but steadily
from, you know, supplying anti-tank weapons in
the very beginning of the war to now supplying
air defense systems, missiles for Ukrainian jets.
I think it's a super interesting development that,
like, we don't really know where it's going
to end. But I think it's really interesting
to focus on that and how the Ukrainian military
is going to transform as this what goes on.
Speaker 1: It could be a dramatically different
military. If this does extend into the years as
many predict it will, the Ukrainian military could
end up coming out of this completely differently
and then than it went in. And it is interesting,
to say the least. Appreciate the call. Thank you.
Speaker 3: Thank you, too.
Speaker 1: All right. Very, very important stuff